हेलो गाइ वेलकम टू आवर
youtube3 का डे नाइन तक कंप्लीट कर लिया
है तो आज हम लोग करने वाले हैं डे 10
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का ठीक है तो मैं
उम्मीद करता हूंगा कि जितने भी पहले के
टास्क थे जितने भी लेक्चर थे वो सब आपने
पूरे कर लिए होंगे कंप्लीट कर लिए होंगे
जितने भी ई डाउट्स अगर आपके होंगे तो
क्लियर हो चुके होंगे कोई है तो उसको पहले
क्लियर कर दीजिएगा
हमेशा कि लिन पे हमारे पेज को फॉलो कर
लीजिए हमारे चैनल को फॉलो कर लीजिए ठीक है
लेके आए रिकॉर्ड एंड सर्वर वाला रूम हम
यहां पर करेंगे ये वाला ठीक है सेकंड वाला
रूम हम बाद में करेंगे इसके बीच में मुझे
लगा कि और चीज ऐड करने की जरूरत है या
एसएमबी और कुछ और प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में
तो इसके बाद हम दूसरे रूम पे जाएंगे ठीक
है जो इस मॉड्यूल के अंदर नहीं होगा लेकिन
वो नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी में एक मेजर जो है
रोल प्ले कर रहा होगा ठीक है तो हम उसको
भी करेंगे बीच में इस रूम के बाद हम उस
रूम को करेंगे उसको कंप्लीट करने के बाद ब
जो एक्स्ट्रा मुझे लगेगा बताऊंगा मैं आपको
साथ में फिर हम लोग यहां से कंटिन्यू
करेंगे क्योंकि हमारा आम कुछ ये तो है
नहीं कि हमें सिर्फ ये कंप्लीट करना है
हमारा आम है जितनी जरूरी चीजें नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी में है प्रोटोकॉल्स और उसको हम
लोग थोड़ डीप पढ़ जाए ठीक है तो इसके बाद
हम दूसरा रूम करेंगे मैं इससे शुरू करता
हूं चलिए तो यहां पर हम लोग पहले अटक
बॉक्स को भी स्टार्ट कर देते हैं य पर
अपने मशीन को भी स्टार्ट कर देते हैं जो
भी य पर टास्क होने वाला है उसके लिए
हमारा टाइम बच
जाएगा स्टार्ट हो रहा पढते हैं आगे क्या
चीज दी हुई है ओके तो इस रूम इस रूम में
हम लोग कई सारे प्रोटोकॉल के बारे में
पढ़ने वाले हैं जैसे एचटीटीपी एफटीपी पीओ
पी3 एसटीपी आई मैप ठीक है अब ये सबसे पहले
आपके लिए एक छोटा सा क्वेश्चन प्रोटोकॉल्स
होते क्या है एक बार सोचिए मन में सोचिए
क्या होता है मैंने आपको बताया ऑलरेडी
प्रोटोकॉल सपोर्ट सटर मैंने आपको बताया है
तो प्रोटोकॉल्स क्या होते हैं मैं आपको
आंसर कर देता हूं इसका प्रोटोकॉल्स एक कह
सकते हैं आपकी सेट ऑफ रूल्स होते हैं कि
कम्युनिकेशन कैसे करना है जैसे एचटीटीपी
के बारे में तो आपने सुना ही होगा पक्का
ठीक है कि कोई वेबसाइट प आपको कम्युनिकेशन
करना है मतलब कोई वेब सर्व से कम्युनिकेशन
करना है तोब एडीडीपी प्रोटोकॉल का
इस्तेमाल करते हैं ठीक है इसमें क्या होता
है कुछ स्टैंडर्ड सेट ऑफ रूल्स है उसके
उसको ध्यान रखते हुए उसके हिसाब से ही आप
कम्युनिकेशन करते हैं ठीक है ये प्रोटोकॉल
का काम होता है बहुत सारे प्रोटोकॉल होते
हैं आपको पता ही है एफटीपी होता है
एचटीटीपी होता है एसएसए होता है टेलनेट
होता है बहु सार होते हैं ठीक है कुछ
बेसिक के बारे में हम यहां पढ़ेंगे यहां
पर ऊपर के जो दो है एटीपी एफटीपी इनके
बारे में तो आपने सुना ही होगा नीचे के जो
तीन है वो थोड़े कम सुने जाते हैं ठीक है
तो इसके बारे में जानेंगे काम कैसे करते
हैं और फिर हम लोग कुछ और प्रोटोकॉल जैसे
कि एसएमबी और एफटीपी के हम लोग जो है
एक्सप्लोइटेशन को भी देखेंगे एफबी को भी
देखेंगे रेशन पूरा मैनुअल सब कुछ देखेंगे
ठीक
है आगे बढ़ते हैं य पर इसको कंप्लीट कर
देते
हैं चालू हो रही है तक आगे बढ़ते हैं यहां
पर टेलनेट प हम शुरुआत य टेलनेट से कर रहे
हैं य शुरु टट से क्यों कर रहे है मेरे
ख्याल से टट मैंने आपको लडी बता रखा है
मैं आप जल्दी से करा दूंगा ठीक है टट
शुरुआत इसलिए कर रहे है क् नेट से हम बाकी
पोर्ट से भी कनेक्शन कर सकते हैं जो कि
एनक्रिप्टेड नहीं होगा ठीक है चलिए य पर
दिया हुआ है एप्लीकेशन मत ये क्या नाम है
आपका टर्मिनल यूज करने के लिए होता है
सिस्टम कमांड करने के लिए य जैसा ही होता
है पर ये एनक्रिप्टेड नहीं होता है ठीक है
रिलेटिवली सिपल वही चीज लिखी हुई है सारी
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड दे कने कर सकते हैं ट से
ट सवर नॉड ठीक है इी होता है इसंग के लिए
डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट इसका 23 होता है आपको पता
ही है चलिए य पर टेलनेट डी नाम का य पर
क्या है नेट
सर्वर स सर्वर है ठीक डी नाम का य पर
स्क्रीनशॉट में दिखाया गया है नेट कमांड
से हमने इस आईपी एड्रेस प कनेक्ट किया है
और हमने पोर्ट नहीं दिया बाय डिफॉल्ट
पोर्ट कौन सा य होगा 23 वाला ठीक है य कु
बेसिक डिफॉल्ट आपको पोर्ट याद होने
चाहिए य पर ये सिनेरियो दिया हुआ है इसने
य पासवर्ड यूज किया है और यूजर नेम यूज
किया ठीक है कमांड ाली आई एडस ला ठीक आगे
इससे यूजर नेम पूछा गया तो य रने डा पासवड
डाला है देखते हमारे पास कोई टास्क है कि
नहीं व चीज य पर दी हुई है देख इसने वकक
से पूरे ट्रैफिक को कैप्चर किया हुआ है तो
इसको जो भी टा मतलब पा में डाला गया है वो
उसको प्लेन टेस्ट में मिल गया है क्योंकि
नेट एनक्रिप्टेड नहीं होता है ठीक है
इसीलिए हम लोग उसका अल्टरनेट में ूज करते
है देख यहां व लिखा है सेक्यर अल्टरनेटिव
इ एसस चलिए ू च पोर्ट विल द टेनेट कमांड
वि डिफॉल्ट पैरामीटर ट्राई टू कनेक्ट ल्ट
कनेक्ट होगा पोर्ट
से बेसिक टट कमांड से आपको रिवा कर रहा था
कमांड आप यूज कर सकते हैं क्यों मैंने या
दिलाया आपको नेट कमांड से हम लोग और भी
दूसरे प्रोटोकॉल से भी ट्रैक करेंगे इ डीड
में ठीक है में यूज कर सकते हैं आप चलिए
एटीपी का भी आपको पता ही डिटेल में य भी
मेरे ख्याल से हमने कवर कर लिया है रेडी
हाइपर टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल होता है
इस तरीके से काम करता है गेट रिक्वेस्ट
पोस्ट बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट होती है इसमें
गेट रिक्वेस्ट हमने की किसी रिसोर्स को
ग्रब करने के लिए जैसे मान लीजिए इक्स ठीक
है हम उसके रिसोर्स जो है मिल गए य चीज इस
कुछ खास अलग से नहीं है अब यहां पर देखिए
नेट थ्र मैंने आपको बैनर बताया मे ल से ट
से कैसे कर सकते सर्वर का हमने क्या किया
य पर करता
हूं पोट
0 न खि पो य पर आपको एटी नहीं करना य ठीक
है य पर कुछ भी भे सकते कोई मैसेज तो नेट
मेंक हम य पर वे सर्वर इट कर रहे हैं तो
हम एक सिंपल सा रिक्वेस्ट भेजेंगे य सिंपल
रिक्वेस्ट का क्या है सिंटेक्स ठीक
है
इसको डबल एंटर करूंगा तो रिक्वे हो जाएगी
रिफ हो रही है ठीक है डबल एंटर करते सड हो
जाएगी पर कुछ आ
गया भी मतलब नहीं कि मतलब है सवर से इस तर
ब मिल सकती है इसको इस्तेमाल कर सकता है
ठीक है य करते या फ य करते टा कीज होती है
ठीक सते मेरे ल हमने देखा हुआ रेडी अभी हम
इसके एक्सटशन एशन प भी आएंगे धीरे-धीरे
ठीक तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है उसमें कुछ यहां
पर पॉपुलर h सर्वर के बारे में दिया हुआ
है अचे आईआई एनिस ठीक है एनिस और अचे ल से
ओपन सोर्स है हां ओपन सोर्स है और ये आपका
आई जो है वो क्लोज सोर्स है चलिए कुछ य पर
ब्राउजर के बारे में दिया है मतलब नहीं है
टास्क देखते हमारा क्या है
लच कनेक्टिंग यूिंग नेट ट द फ्लैग हमें प
कनेक्ट करना है इस आईपी एड्रेस प हम अपना
अटैक बॉक्स चालू कर लेते हैं चालू तो है
ही रेडी ओपन कर लेते हैं ये सीरीज एकदम
चिल होक आराम से चल रही है ठीक है अभी
हमने ना लेक्चर ऑलरेडी कर लिया है तो ये
एकदम आराम से चल रही है तो मैं उमीद करता
हूं इसको आप पूरा ही फॉलो कर रहे होंगे
बाकी चीज आपके बैकल लग रहे तो उसको
कंप्लीट करते रहिए साथ में इसको भी करते
गा ठीक है इसको मत छोड़िएगा ये काफी एक
इंपोर्टेंट चीज
हैलिए आई एडस को य पर कॉपी कर लेता
हूं नेट से हमें कनेक्ट करना है इस प
कनेक्ट करना है चलिए अब हम काम कर करते
सिंपल सा एक गेट रिक्वेस्ट भेजते
हैं य पर क्या आया
400 ओके ओके बैड
रिक्वेस्ट हमें फ्लग डटी चाहिए मेरे ख्याल
से हमें य गेट रिक्वेस्ट फ्लग प करनी
पड़ेगी गेट रिक्वेस्ट क्या होता है मैंने
आपको बताया कोई भी रिसोर्स को ग्रब करने
के लिए फ्लग डटी
ए
डबल एंटर करते हैं इसको आ
[संगीत]
गया हम हो करना पड़ेगा हो सकता
है पर होस्ट को करने के लिए कहा नहीं गया
है चाहे तो होस्ट में इसी आई एडस को स् कर
सकते हैं इसको भी ट्राई कर लिया जाए
ब हमने कर लिया है गेट रिक्वेस्ट हम
भेजेंगे फ्लग डटी एम प
हमारा जो होस्ट
होगा यही सेम आईपी एड्रेस होगा अब इसको
डबल एंटर करते हैं चलिए देखिए यहां पर
क्या हुआ डिफरेंस क्या था कि पहली बार
हमने क्या किया था यहां पर होस्ट का
इस्तेमाल नहीं किया था ठीक है कौन सा हेडर
का आ गया डर ये रहा होस्ट हेडर का ठीक है
इस्तेमाल हमने नहीं किया था अब मैं आपको
बता दूं होस्ट हेडर कहां पे काम आ सकता है
केज सता है कि होस्टर क्यों इस्तेमाल कर
सकते हैं ठीक है आपने सुना होगा कि बहुत
सारी वेबसाइट ऐसी होती है जैसे आपने सुना
होगा कि शेयर्ड होस्टिंग या इस टाइप की
चीज जहां पे आप एक ही सर्वर पर मल्टीपल
वेबसाइट को होस्ट कर सकते हैं या आपने
वर्चुअल होस्टिंग कांसेप्ट सुना होगा ठीक
है मतलब उसमें आप सकते हैं कि मतलब एक ही
सर्वर पे एक ही आईपी एडस प आप बहुत सारी ब
साइट चला रहे हैं ठीक है जैसे आप यहां पर
दिखाता हूं मैं आपको य चीज भी देखिए यहां
पर स्सी स् सोर्स में यहां पर कुछ चीज सेट
है ठीक है यहां पर उस तरीके से और चीज सेट
होती है इससे क्या होता है कि आपका मतलब
एक ही सर्वर पे एक ही आईपी एड्रेस प आप
मल्टीपल वेबसाइट रन कर सकते हैं और जब कोई
यूजर उसको रिक्वेस्ट करेगा तो वो अपने एक
सा करेगा और होस्ट में जो भी वैल्यू होगी
व उसी वेबसाइट को आपको सर्व कर देगा आपका
सर्वर ठीक है य कन का होता है वर्चुल
होस्टिंग वाला मतलब की आप एक ही जो सर्वर
पर मल्प को होस्ट कर रहे लिएने होस्ट
इस्तेमाल किया का और भी काम उसके बेसिक य
आप सम
सकते सरी फलने कॉपी नहीं किया दोबारा इसको
लेते
ब गेट रिक्वेस्ट किया फ्लग टीम पर
एचटीटीपी 1.1 के साथ पोस्ट हमने स्पेसिफाई
कर दिया यही और फिर डबल एंटर कर दिया य
हमें फ्लैग मिल गया कॉपी कर लेते
हैं य पर आप और चीज भी स् कर सकते हैं जो
ब्राउजर करता है जैसे कि आप यूजर एजेंट और
बाकी चीज ठीक है उतने की जरूरत नहीं थी
इतने से हमारा काम हो गया तो हमने इतना ही
किया ठीक है और भी कर सकते है चलिए तो का
एक ओवरव्यू हो गया वापस हमने कराया था
ऑलरेडी एफटीपी का एक ओवरव्यू अभी हम इसके
एक्सप्लोरेशन पे आएंगे ठीक है बारी-बारी
से अगले रूम में आएंगे तो चिंता करने की
को जरूरत नहीं है कि स्किप होरहा स्किप
कुछ नहीं हो रहा है ये तो सिर्फ बेसिक अल
रूम है ये ठीक है ये रिवीजन के लिए है
चलिए सा मॉड्यूल भी होता रहेगा एटी भी देख
लेते हैं एफटीपी क्या है एफटीपी आपको पता
है ऑलरेडी कि क्या होता है फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल ठीक है ये भी क्लियर टेक्स्ट ही
होता है इस इनफैक्ट मेरे खल जितने है सब
क्लियर टेक्स्ट ही है एनेट भी क्लियर
टेक्स्ट है ए भी क् टेक्स्ट है एफटीपी भी
है और यहां पर कौन सा है देख लेते हैं
एसटीपी हां ठीक है यहां पर सारे क्लिय
टेक्स्ट वाले ही
है
चलिए यहां पर भी वही चीज है क्या नाम है
कि जो डिफॉल्ट प 21 होता है हां एक और चीज
इंपोर्टेंट एफटीपी के बारे में आपको बताना
चाहूंगा एफटीपी आपके दो चैनल्स क्रिएट
करता है ठीक है एक आपका कम्युनिकेशन चैनल
होता है एक आपका डेटा चैनल होता है एक तो
मतलब कमांड के लिए होता है नर्मल कमांड हो
रहा है दूसरे चैनल को क्रिएट करता है अपने
डाटा को भेजने के लिए अब इसमें भी आप क
सकते हैं कि दो मोड होते हैं इसमें ठीक है
एफटीपी में दो मोड होते हैं एक्टिव मोड और
पैसिव मोड एक्टिव मोड में क्या हो रहा है
देखिए इन एक्टिव मोड द डाटा इ से ओवर अ
सेपरेट चैनल ओरिजनेटिंग फ्रॉम एफटीपी
सर्वर्स ठीक है प 20 यहां पर एफटीपी सर्वर
जो है वो क्या करता है कनेक्शन को
इनिशिएटिव
मोड में क्या होता है पैसिव मोड में क्या
होता है एफटीपी क्लाइंट जो है यानी आप
इनिशिएटिव
मोड और पैसिव मोड का इसके बारे में हम और
डिटेल में फिर से देखेंगे आगे दूसरे रूम
में एक्सप्लोइटेशन वाले रूम में ठीक है
चलिए यहां पर आप कमांड डाल के टाइप ए करके
आप एई मोड में एई आप जानते होंगे अमेरिकन
स्टैंड कोड ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन इंटरचेंज ठीक है
इसका आपका मतलब समते कोई भी दूसरी वलू को
रिप्रेजेंट करने के लिए ए से ज या इन टाइप
की वैल्यू को नंबर रिप्रेजेंट करने के लिए
ठीक हैसे पता होगा अने कमांड स् और सब में
आपने काम किया होगा प्रोग्राम आपने कंपेयर
किया होगा तोई कोड के थ कंपेयर होता है तो
उससे आपको अ लग रहा होगा तो ये उसके उसम
ट्रांसफर करने के लिए टाइप आई कर देंगे तो
चले जाएंगे फाइ ट्रांसर करनी है व आप य से
कर सकते है यटी की चीज है लेकिन पैस जाने
के लिए आप प कमांड य कर सकते कमांड ठीक है
मोड दो होते है ये तो कांसेप्ट सेम ही
रहेगा हर जगह चाहे आपका टीप क्लांट यूज
कीजिए वही चीज करके दिखाया गया है कुछ खास
नहीं है देखा रेडी वही चीज दी हुई है
कंट्रोल चैनल और डटा चैनल ठीक है इससे
कमांड होता है इससे टा ंस वाला आपका काम
हो रहा है ठीक है ना ही चीज यहां दी हुई
है कुछ नया दिया है यहां पर ये बेसिक
कमांड है गेट फाइल गेट से आप कोई फाइल ले
सकते हैं ये सब हमारा नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
जितना बेसिक पढ़ लेंगे करने के बाद मैं
आपको एक दो मतलब आपके लिए सीटीएफ भी
लाऊंगा ठीक है मतलब हमारा ा सीटीएफ भी
करेंगे जिसमें पोरली नेटवर्क बे चैलेंस
होंगे ठीक है उसमें हम पूरा हैंड्स ऑन
एक्सटशन करेंगे जितने कांसेप्ट हमने सीखे
हैं सबको मिला के मिक्स करके और जो भी
मुझे नया लगेगा वो आपको
बताऊंगा
चलिए य पर कुछ फेमस एफटीपी सर्व एग्जांपल
दिया हुआ हैसे एटीपीडी प्रो एफटीपीडी ठीक
है यूटीपी ये दोनों आपने ल सुना भी होगा
ऊपर वाला चलिए आगे बढ़ते य पर यहां पर भी
एक टास्क हुआ है यूिंग ए एटीपी क्ला
कनेक्ट टू दम ट्रा टू रिकर द फ्लैग हमें
फ्रैंक प कनेक्ट करना है ठीक है यूजर
है हमारा और ये हमारा क्या है पासवर्ड और
कौन सा आईपी एड्रेस हमारा ये है आईपी
एड्रेस कनेक्ट कर देते हैं इसको य पर यूजर
नेम पूछ रहा है तो यूजर नेम हमने क्या
डालना है
फ्रैंक पासवर्ड यहां पर पूछा हुआ
है अभी हम बेसिक देख रहे हैं ठीक है ना
वापस अभी इन मिसकंफीग्रेशन को भी पढ़ेंगे
उसकी टेंशन मत लीजिएगा य पर लॉगिन
सक्सेसफुल हो गया है यहां पर हम लोग एस पर
देख सकते हैं कि क्या जो है यहां पर
फाइल्स रखी हुई है यहां पर एफटीपी अंड
फ्लैग टीम है बो सकते है गेट एफटीपी क्या
काम कर रहा कोई नहीं
फ्लैग
डटी ये हमारा आ गया ठीक है 39 बा अब इसको
बाय करके एट कर दीजिए अब यहां पर एस
करेंगे तो आपको अपने सिस्टम में मिल जाएगा
वही
चीज ये हमारा जो फ्लैग हम मिल गया
है
अगर आप ऐसा ही कोई मतलब इस वीडियो को पहली
बार देख रहे हैं मतलब आप डायरेक्टली सीरीज
को यहीं से कंटिन्यू कर रहे हैं इसी
वीडियो से तो आपको फिलहाल तो यनी चीजें
आगे समझ में आएंगी क्योंकि एक तरीके का
बेसिक रिवीजन ही है वापस से ठीक है इसके
बाद इसका एक्सप्लोरेशन करने वाले हैं फ
मैं तो ये रिकमेंड करूंगा कि सारे
स्टार्टिंग से देखिए तो आपको बेहतर तरीके
से हर चीज समझ में आएगी चलिए अब तो ये
बेसिक वाले वो प्रोटोकॉल्स हो गए पहले
जिनके बारे में आपने बारबार सुना था अभी
ठीक है अब हम थोड़े और देखेंगे जिसके बारे
में आपने बारबार नहीं सुना होगा मतलब
हमारे लेक्चर में भी अभी नहीं सुना होगा त
ठीक है तो एसएमटीपी के बारे में बात करने
वाले हैं हम लोग एटीपी का हो सकता है आपको
फुल फॉर्म पता हो सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल तो ये करता क्या है ये आपके मेल
में काम आता है ठीक है अब कैसे काम करता
है वो हम देखने वाले हैं और इसमें कुछ
टर्मिनोलॉजी है उसके बारे में हम समझेंगे
याद करने की जरूरत नहीं है मुझे भी याद
नहीं है किसी को याद नहीं रहती है ठीक है
हो सकता है जो इसमें स्पेसिफिकली काम कर
रहा हो उसको याद हो पर आपको एक मतलब ऊपर
ऊपर से पता होना चाहिए और आपके पास नोट
कंप्लीट होनी चाहिए चीजों के ठीक है ताकि
आप जब जिस चीज प करना चाहे उसको आप आराम
से रिवाइज कर सके पढ़
सके यहां पर लिखा हुआ है ईमेल इ वन ऑफ द
मोस्ट यूज सर्विस ये तो पता ही है सबको
यहां पर लिखा हुआ है कि आप अपने खुद के
ईमेल सर्विस को सेट कर सकते हैं इवन विथ
नो इंटरनेट एक्सेस अपने सिस्टम के अंदर इन
सर्वर्स का इस्तेमाल करके ठीक है इन
प्रोटोकॉल्स का इस्तेमाल करके इसमें
क्या-क्या रिक्वायर्ड कंपोनेंट्स होते हैं
ईमेल डिलीवरी में ठीक है ओवर द इंटरनेट की
हम बात करने वाले हैं यहां पे ओवर द
इंटरनेट मेल सबमिशन एजेंट जिसको हम एमएसए
से रिप्रेजेंट करेंगे मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट
एमटीए मेल डिलीवरी एजेंट एमडीए और मेल
यूजर एजेंट एम यूए ठीक है ये चार चीजों का
हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं ये देखिए ये एक
ओवरऑल डायग्राम है इसका कैसे यहां पर पूरा
कंप्लीट जो साइकिल है वो वर्क कर रही है
पर हम इसको यहां पर टेक्स्ट से पढ़ते हैं
आपको और समझ में आएगा मैं आपको डायग्राम
बताऊंगा ठीक है देखिए एम यूए क्या है
सिंपली आपका एक ईमेल क्लाइंट है एम यूए एम
यूए मतलब क्या फुल फॉर्म सच एक ब मन में
मेल यूजर एजेंट ठीक है एमय मतलब मेल यूजर
एजेंट कहने का मतलब क्या है जैसे आप कोई
भी मतलब एप्लीकेशन इस्तेमाल कर रहे हैं जो
कि आपका एक आपकी तरफ जैसे अगर आप कोई वेब
सर्वर ओपन करते हैं तो आपका ब्राउजर आपका
यूजर एजेंट होता है ठीक है उस तरीके से
आपका मेल यूजर एजेंट जो है वो आपका एक कोई
भी मेल क्लाइंट है
चलिए यहां पर आपका एमयूस आपने क्या किया
हैज एन ईमेल मैसेज टू बी सेंड ठीक है मतलब
एमय के पास यानी आपके पास एक ईमेल जो आपको
भेजना है तो एमए क्या करेगा एमए कनेक्ट टू
द मेल सबमिशन एजेंट ठीक है इसके नाम समझ
में आ रहा है मेल सबमिशन एजेंट यानी इसके
पास क्या सबमिट किए जाएंगे मेल सबमिट किए
जाएंगे आपका एमए यानी आपका जो मेल यूजर
एजेंट है वो आपके एमएसए यानी मेल सबमिशन
एजेंट को क्या क्या देगा अपना ईमेल देगा
ठीक है उसने मैसेज भेज दिया मैसेज हो गया
ठीक है एमएसए रिसीव द मैसेज ठीक है मेल
सबमिशन एजेंट को क्या मिल गया मैसेज मिल
गया चेक फॉर एनी एरर बिफोर ट्रांसफरिंग इट
टू द मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट ठीक है मेल
सबमिशन एजेंट क्या करेगा चेक कर सब कुछ
सही है तो वो एमटीए दे देगा ठीक है अब
देखिए डायग्राम में स्लैश करके क्यों बना
हुआ है ये एमएससी और एमटीए ही में क्योंकि
मोस्टली ये एक ही जगह इंप्लीमेंट हो जाता
है इसलिए बना हुआ है ये चीज ठीक है ना
देखिए लिखा हुआ यहां पर कॉमनली होस्टेड ऑन
द सेम सर्वर ठीक है आपका मोस्टली यहां पर
जिसमें आपको सबमिट जिस मतलब जहां प आपने
सबमिट किया है वो और जिसको चेक करना है
ठीक है वो एक ही जगह है ठीक है इसलिए मेल
ट्रांसफर मतलब उसको आगे भेजना है ट्रांसफर
करना है अब चलिए एमटीए विल सेंड द ईमेल
मैसेज टू द एमटी ऑफ द रिसिपिएंट ठीक है
मतलब क्या यहां पर जैसे मान लीजिए यहां पर
आपने कोई ईमेल भेजा ठीक है ये आपका मेल
सबमिशन एजेंट है और आपका मेल ट्रांसफर
एजेंट है ठीक है जो कि एक ही सर्वर पे
होस्टेड है उसको रिसीव हुआ उसने मेल
सबमिशन एजेंट ने सारे एरर सब चेक की गुड
टू गो है उसने अपने एमटीए को दे दिया अब
एमटीए क्या करेगा अब एमटीए का चेकिंग का
काम नहीं है चेकिंग काम किसका था एमएसए का
था अब एमटीए क्या करेगा एमटीए उस मेल को
रिसिपिएंट या जिसने आपको आपको जिसको भेजना
है वो मेल उसके मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट के पास
भेज देगा ठीक है ये उसके मेल ट्रांसफर
एजेंट के पास आ गया ठीक है अब इसके पास
क्या है यहां पर एमडीए है इसका एमटीए और
एमडीए एक ही जगह है ठीक है एमडीए क्या है
मेल डिलीवरी एजेंट ठीक है इसके बते हैं
आगे द एमटी कैन आल्सो फंक्शन एज द मेल
सबमिशन एजेंट वही चीज लिखा हुआ है कि एक
ही में हो सकता है उस तर भी काम कर सकता
है चाहे आप ये लीजिए कि सेम सर्वर पे
होस्टेड है चलिए अ टिपिकल सेटअप वुड हैव द
एमटीए सर्वर आल्सो फंक्शनिंग एस अ मेल
डिलीवरी एजेंट ठीक है यही चीज मैंने आपने
य लिखा हुआ है कि एमटी आपका एमडी काम करता
है ठीक है मतलब एक ही सर्वर पे ये दोनों
होते हैं तो आप क सकते हैं एक तरीके से ये
तीनों चीजें एक ही सर्वर पे है क्योंकि
आपके लिए जो मेल सबमिशन एजेंट है आपके लिए
जो एमटीए है आपको मेल मिलेगा भी तो नहीं
कि आप सिर्फ मेल भेजते रहेंगे आपको मेल
आएगा नहीं आएगा भी तो एमडीए भी यहां पर है
ठीक है ना चलिए द रिसिपिएंट विल कलेक्ट
इट्स ईमेल फ्रॉम द एमडीए यूजिंग देर ईमेल
क्लाइंट अब वो अपने मेल यूजर एजेंट यानी
अपने ईमेल क्लाइंट के थ्रू जब चाहेगा
लेटेस्ट मैसेज को रिट्रीव कर लेगा कहां से
एमडीए से मेल डिलीवरी एजेंट से ठीक है ना
तो भेजने का काम एमटीए ने किया एक्सेप्ट
करने का काम भी एमटीए ने किया दूसरे सर्वर
के और एमटीए लेने के बाद उसको एमडीए को
पास कर दिया यानी ट को डिवर करने का सारा
काम जो है वो एमडीए का है चलिए अब देखिए इ
द अब स्टेप्स साउंड कन्फ्यूजिंग कंसीडर द
फॉलोइंग एनालॉजी ठीक है इस एक बहुत बढ़िया
एनालॉजी दी हुई है आपको ये चीज समझाने के
लिए ठीक है अगर आपको ये समझने में थोड़ा
बत कंफ्यूजन हुआ है तबके लिए मैं इसको अगर
आपके लिए हिंदी में अच्छे से समझा देता
हूं फिर से रिपीट करके अगर आपको कहीं भी
कंफ्यूजन हुआ है तो कोई डाउट होगा तो आप
पूछ ही सकते हैं वो तो चलिए आप मान लीजिए
जो एमय यानी मेल रेजेंट ठीक है वस टू सेंड
ईमेल ठीक है यानी एक पोस्ट भेजना है मान
लीजिए आपको एक पोस्ट भेजना है तो आप क्या
है आप एक एमय है एमल यूजर एजेंट है
क्योंकि आपको एक चिट्ठी भेजनी है ठीक है द
पोस्ट ऑफिस एंप्लॉई जो एंप्लॉई है चेक द
पोस्टल मेल फॉर इशू बिफोर योर लोकल पोस्ट
ऑफिस एक्सेप्टेड ठीक है आपका यहां पर क्या
है जो पोस्ट ऑफिस का जो एंप्लॉई है वो
आपका एमएसए है यानी मेल सबमिशन एजेंट जो
चेक करेगा कुछ एरर तो नहीं है किसी चीज
में ठीक है चिट्ठी में कोई दिक्कत तो नहीं
है इसके बाद वो क्या करेगा वो अपने पोस्ट
ऑफिस में जमा कर देगा यानी एमटीए में मे
ट्रांसफर एजेंट में जमा कर देगा अब द लोकल
पोस्ट ऑफिस चेक्स द मेल डेस्टिनेशन एमटीए
ने डेस्टिनेशन चेक किया एंड सेंड टू द
पोस्ट ऑफिस एमटीए इन द करंट कंट्री ठीक है
मतलब क्या आपके पोस्ट ऑफिस में जिस पोस्ट
ऑफिस में भेजना था वहां का एड्रेस चेक
किया यानी एमके टीए ने मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट
ने एड्रेस चेक किया और सही पोस्ट ऑफिस पे
आपका चिट्ठी भेज दिया यानी सही मेल
ट्रांसफर एजेंट के पास आपका ईमेल भेज दिया
ठीक है द पोस्ट ऑफिस एमटीए डिलीवर्स द मेल
टू द
रेसिपिटिन रिसिपिएंट के मेल बॉक्स में
डिलीवर किया ठीक है ना ये एमडीए में मेल
डि एजेंट में मतलब यहां से आप कलेक्ट कर
सकते हैं वहां पे डिवर हो गया अब एम यूए
यानी आप जिसको चाहिए था डेस्टिनेशन भी तो
एक एम यूए ही है वो रेगुलरली चेक करता
रहेगा ठीक है अपने मेल बॉक्स को ठीक है
मेल बॉक्स मतलब आप समझ सकते हैं कि इंडिया
में तो मेरे खल से उतना नहीं होता बाहर
होता है जैसे अपने अग कार्टून देखे होंगे
तो उसमें दिखाता था कि केट्स के बाहर एक
मेल बॉक्स बना हुआ है वहां पोस्टमन आ रहा
है चिठी ल चला जा रहा है ठीक है वो यहां
पर उसकी बात हो रही है आप ना चिठी वाला
डब्बा चेक कर रहे हैं ठीक है वहां प आपको
अपना ईमेल मिल रहा है तो आप क्या हुए एमय
हुए ठीक है और आप एमडीएस चेक कर रहे हैं
उमीद करता हूं आपको समझ में आ गया होगा एक
बार आपको दोबारा से थोड़ ट्राई करता हूं
क्योंकि ये थोड़ा हो सकता है आपके लिए कुछ
लोगों के लिए मतलब लिए सता कुछ लोगों के
लिए थोड़ा कन्फ्यूजिंग हो देख लेते हैं तो
ये आप मान लीजिए ठीक है
इसको य आप है ठीक
है कीजिए य आप है आपको क्या करना है आपको
एक ईमेल भेजना है ठीक है आपको एक क्या
भेजना है ईमेल भेजना है आप क्या है आप है
एम यू ए राइटिंग नहीं जागा ठीक है माउ लिख
रहा मेल य आपको क्या भेजना है आपको एक
ईमेल भेजना है ठीक है धन समगा आराम से
दोबारा बता रहा धीरे बता बार आपको आप है
मेल यूजर एजेंट आपको भेजना है एक ईमेल ठीक
है आपने उस ईमेल को
भेजा
अपने मेल
सबमिशन एजेंट पास ठीक है मेल सबमिशन एजेंट
के पास य मेल सबमिशन एजेंट जो है व आपके
मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट जैसा भी वर्क कर रहा
है ठीक है आपने अपने मेल सबमिशन एजेंट को
भेजा उसने मेल सबमिशन मतलब मे चेक किया
सबमिट किया ठीक है फिर अपने मेल ट्र को
भेज दिया अब मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट ने ओवर द
क्या अगर आप इंटरनेट की बात करते हैं तो
ओवर
द टरनेट ठीक है डिंग य पर ओवर द इंटरनेट
रेसिपिटिन ट्रांसफर एजेंट है वो मेल
ट्रांसफर एजेंट के साथ साथ मेल डिलीवरी
एजेंट यानी एमडीए की तरह भी काम करेगा ठीक
है जब उसको मिला ईमेल तो उसने एमडी को दे
दिया कि भाई लो सब कुछ सही है ईमेल आ गया
है जब यूजर मागे दे देना अब आपका
डेस्टिनेशन य आपका डेस्टिनेशन है ठीक है
डेस्टिनेशन को भी चाहिए डेस्टिनेशन य से
क्या कर लेगा अपने ईमेल्स
को रिट्रीव कर देगा ठीक
है समझ आया आपको य पर क्या हो रहा है ठीक
है और समझ में आ फिर भी अगर कोई डाउट है
किसी को दोबारा एक बार पूछ लीजिएगा ये
इंपोर्टेंट है समझना ठीक है ना य को खुद
से कर लीजिएगा मेरे ल से शायद तो नहीं ये
वाली है ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अगर
वाउचर है तो अच्छी बात है नहीं है तो यहां
सेहे स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए जो टेस्ट मैंने
लिखा है तो मैं तो बता ही रहा हूं उसको
नोट बना चलिए ठीक है ये अच्छी चीज है
समझने के लिए चलिए इन द सेम वे व नी टू
फॉलो प्रोटोकॉल टू कम्युनिकेट विथ एन
एचटीटीपी सर्वर एंड वी नीड टू रिलाई न
प्रोटोकॉल्स टू टॉक विथ एन एमटीए एंड
एमडीए द प्रोटोकॉल्स आर एसएमटीपी और पोस्ट
ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन थी ठीक है यहां पर
हमने क्या किया यहां पर जो हमने पूरा
कम्युनिकेशन किया वो कैसे किया जैसे वेब
सर्वर से जब हम कोई कम्युनिकेशन करते हैं
वेब सर्वर से ठीक है तो हम क्या यूज करते
हैं वेब सर्वर से कम्युनिकेशन कर के लिए
हम एटीटीपी यूज करते हैं उसी तरीके से ये
सारा कम्युनिकेशन हो तो रहा है मैंने बता
दिया कि ये सारा कम्युनिकेशन जो है वो हो
रहा है वो कम्युनिकेशन हो कैसे रहा है
उसके लिए हम स्वाल करेंगे जैसे कि
एसएमटीपी और पॉप थ या फिर आई मैप का ठीक
है अब ये सब क्या होते हैं इसके बारे में
भी हम पढ़ने वाले हैं चलिए पहले एटीपी देख
लेते हैं सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल इज
यूज कम्युनिकेट विथ एन एमटीए सर्वर ठीक है
यानी मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट ठीक है बिकॉज
एसएमटीपी यूस क्लियर टेक्स्ट वेर ऑल
कमांड्स आर सेंट विदाउट एंक्रिप्शन वी कैन
यूज अ बेसिक ट क्लाइंट टू कनेक्ट टू ए
सर्वर मैंने आपको रेडी कहा कि जो बेसिक
क्लियरटेक्स्ट यूज कर रहे हैं उसको आप नेट
से कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं ठीक है यहां पर
क्या हो रहा है देखिए एंड एक्ट एज एन ईमेल
क्लाइंट ठीक है हम एक ईमेल क्लाइंट की तरह
का एक्ट करने वाले हैं टेलनेट के थ्रू
मतलब ह टेलनेट क्लाइंट रहेगा टेलनेट
क्लाइंट क्या होता है लेट क्ट मतलब आप जो
कमांड यूज कर रहे हैं कनेक्ट करने के लिए
तो आप कोई यूटिलिटी यूज कर र है कनेक्ट
करने के लिए नेट सर्वर से या कोई भी सर्वर
से व नेट क्लाइंट है वो आपके एक मेल यूजर
एजेंट की तरह काम करेगा ठीक है और आप अपने
मेल ट्रांसफर एजेंट से कम्युनिकेट करेंगे
किससे कम्युनिकेट करेंगे मेल ट्रांसफर
एजेंट यानी इससे कम्युनिकेट करेंगे ठीक है
चलिए और ये कम्युनिकेशन कैसे होगा आपके
एसटीपी के थ्रू होगा ठीक है एमटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू होगा चलिए पूरा काम
एसटीपी से नहीं हो रहा है सिर्फ इतना काम
एटीपी से हो रहा है ठीक है ल से टा भी
करना होगा क्या देख लेते है
चलिए बॉक्स कनेक्ट ठीक है इससे हम एटी से
कनेक्ट करना है चलिए इसको मैं पहले यहां
पर क्लियर कर देता हूं टेलनेट
से 23 एटीपी ठीक है कक्ट करते
है
क्या 23 क् कह रहा हूं यार मैं सॉरी 25
होगा 23 तो उसका होता है ना क्या नाम है
टेलनेट का ये देखिए सामने ये आ गया कनेक्ट
करते ही आपको यहां पर एक फ्लैग मिल गया
चलिए कॉपी कर लेते हैं
इसको यहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं यहां पर
टास्क में कुछ था नहीं इसको पढ़ ही लेते
हैं ठीक है चलिए यहां पर बेसिकली कुछ मतलब
एसटीपी के कुछ कमांड्स के बारे दिया हुआ
है ठीक है ना क्या काम होता है तो आप समझ
गए ठीक है बाय डिफॉल्ट 25 पट य होता है वो
भी ठीक है अब हमने क्या यूज किया टट कमांड
यूज किया और हमारा कनेक्ट करने प कुछ इस
तरीके से आ देखिए ये कनेक्शन हुआ ठीक है
यहां पर कनेक्शन हुआ यहां कनेक्शन था ठीक
है इसके बाद यहां पर इस तरीके से आपको
मैसेज आ गया कि आप कनेक्ट हो चुके हैं अब
यहां पर क्या इसने लिखा हेलो टेलनेट ठीक
है ये आपको क्या मिलेगा इससे बेसिक से
आपको एक वो है मतलब बन कह सकते हैं वो मिल
रहा है आपको ठीक है चलिए य पर क्या लिखा
हुआ है व इशू हेलो हो एंड देन स्टार्ट
टाइपिंग अवर
ईमेल चलिए लिखते है आफ्टर हेलो वी इशू मेल
फ्रॉम आरसीपीटी टू ू रिसिपिएंट मेल फ्रॉम
कोलन ये देखिए यहां पर मेल फ्रॉम कोलन लगा
के हमने क्या लिखा है अपना उसको मेल भेजना
है और आरसीपीटी टू ठीक है आरसीपीटी टू से
कहां पे सॉरी मेल फ्रॉम मतलब कहां से आया
है और आरसीपीटी टू मतलब किसको भेजना है
रिसिपिएंट ठीक है वो हमने इंडिकेट किया और
फिर डाटा लिखने के बाद हमने क्या किया
देखिए वी शू द कमांड डाटा एंड टाइप आवर
मैसेज ठीक है हमने डाटा लिखा फिर क्या
किया अपना जो है मैसेज लिखा देखिए सीर एल
एफ डॉट सीर एल एफ ठीक है और एंटर डॉट एंटर
टू पुट इट इन सिंपल टर्न ठीक है यहां पर
आपको पूरा मैसेज लिखने के बाद आपको क्या
करना है एंटर दबाना है फिर डॉट दबाना है
फिर एंटर दबाना है इसको ट्राई करते हैं
ठीक ठीक है पहले इनका करते हैं हेलो
टेलनेट चलिए ये कनेक्ट हो गया ठीक है हेलो
टेलनेट अब हम क्या करने वाले हैं अब यहां
पर मेल
फ्रॉम करने वाले हैं मेरे ल से य पर इसने
कुछ डाला नहीं है फिर भी हम डल देते हैं
कुछ मा लीजिए आ लिख देता हूं मैं चलिए
आरसीपीटी रेस पेंट रेसिप टू हो गया ेंट टू
ठीक
है डि फोनिक्स ठीक है
चलिए य पर आ गया एड्रेस रिजेक्टेड यूजर अन
लोकल ट टेबल चलिए य पर यूजर नहीं है काम
करते हैं आरसी पटी टू एटर कर देते
हैं क्या करने वा ने वाले टा कमांड ठीक
है नहीं है कोई भी लिए इ हो रहा
है शो नहीं कर
पाऊंगा
होती है ठीक है ना य पर मैं आपको
प्रैक्टिकल सता इस ऐसा कोई टास्क दिया ही
नहीं है फ मैं आपको एसटीपी के लिए देखता
हूं रिसोर्स अगर कुछ अच्छा होगा तो मैं
आपको प्रैक्टिकल दिखाऊंगा इस चीज का बाद
में ठीक है ना अभी के लिए आगे बढ़ते हैं
यहां पर ये ऑलरेडी दिया हुआ है वी डोंट
नीड टू मेमराइज कमांड्स वही चीज जो मैं
बोलता हूं हमेशा कि आपको याद करने की
जरूरत नहीं है ठीक है जो चीज कि आप
मोस्टली जो चीजों प आप रोज वर्क करते हैं
डेली वर्क करते हैं उन डायरेक्टली ची शीट
होनी चाहिए ठीक है और बाकी बची चीजों को
आप रख सकते हैं दिमाग में रख सकते हैं पर
आपको याद रखने की जरूरत नहीं है ठीक है ज
आपको जरूरत होगी आप सिंपल
प्रोटोकॉल कमांड ठीक है आपको डायरेक्टली
मिल जाएगा आपको चीज याद करने की कोई जरूरत
नहीं है ना इतना किसी को याद हो पाता है
ठीक है ना हो भी नहीं पाएगा वो चीज तो
जरूरत नहीं है उसकी उसकी टेंशन नहीं लेनी
है ठीक है आपको बस ओल पता होना चाहिए काम
कैसे करता है हो आप इनमें से भी किसी चीज
के नाम भूल जाए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है इसमें
इतना पनिकल चीज नहीं है बस आपको समझ में
आना चाहिए काम कैसे हो रहा है चलिए अब ये
तो एमटीपी का काम हो गया क्या काम हो गया
एसएमटीपी का एम यूए से एमएससी कनेक्ट करना
ठीक है अब इसमें पीओपी थ आई क्या काम है
उस काम आगे आता है ठीक है पढ़ते हैं अब
पीओपी थ को जो क्या है पोस्ट ऑफिस
प्रोटोकॉल थ्री वर्जन थ ठीक है अब ये क्या
है यूज श डाउनलोड द ईमेल मैसेज फ्रॉम मेल
डिलीवरी सर्वर ठीक है क्या कर रहा है आपने
भेज दिया ठीक है एटीपी से लेकिन आपको क्या
चाहिए मैसेज डाउनलोड करना है मेल डिलीवरी
एजेंट से वहां पर काम आता है किसका पीओ 3
और आई का यह नाम आपने अक्सर देखे होंगे जब
आप अपने फोन में कोई ईमेल ऐड करते हैं या
ओल्ड फोन में ज्यादातर होते चीज ठीक है
मेल ऐड करते तो वहां पर आपको दिखता है
ऑप्शन पीओ और सब का ठीक है वो यही चीज
होती है अगर आपको मेल डाउनलोड करना है तो
वहां पर आप काम आता है पीओ थ
चलिए
यहां पर पीओ और आई को काम आता है ठीक है
इसके बार बता दोन में डिफरेंस क्या वो भी
देखेंगे पले आगे बढ़ते य पर बेसिक से यन
वही चीज हुई है इस नेट यूज किया है कनेक्ट
किया है ठीक है य कने किया यूजर इसने फंक
दिया है ओके हो गया पासवर्ड इसने दिया है
कनेक्ट हो गया ठीक है आपको लगन करने के
लिए पास देना ही पड़ेगा ठीक है फिर आपको
क्या मिल रहा है यहां पर देखिए यहां पर
कमांड डाली गई है प्लस ओके और न 179 ठीक
ये रिप्लाई है सॉय रिप्लाई है आपका यहां
पर स्टेट यानी स्टेटस ठीक है यहा तो गेट
रिप्लाई अब रिप्लाई का मतलब क्या है इसका
मतलब है प्लस ओके यानी सब कुछ कमांड सही
से हुई है ठीक है पॉजिटिव रिस्पांस हो गया
आपका अब इसका जो सिंटेक्स है वो कुछ इस
तरीके का है प्लस ओके एन ए एम एम जहां एन
एन क्या है नंबर ऑफ ईमेल मैसेज इन द
इनबॉक्स ठीक है मतलब आपके कितने इनबॉक्स
में ईमेल इस टाइम है करेंटली ए ये
रिप्रेजेंट कर रहा है और एमएम क्या हैकी
टोटल साइज क्या है ठीक है बाइट्स में टोटल
साइज क्या है वो यहां पर जो है डिनोट कर
रहा है लिस्ट कमांड आप क्या कर रहा है
न्यू मैसेजेस दे रहा है और आरटीआर रिट्रीव
ठीक है वन ये आपके पहले मैसेज को रिट्रीव
कर रहा है ठीक है ना अब देखिए आगे वही
चीजें रिपीट हो रही है वी डोंट नीड टू
कंसर्न आवर सेल्फ मेमोराइजेशन मेमोराइजिंग
दिस कमांड्स ठीक है वही बात है याद करने
की कोई जरूरत नहीं है चलिए इसको मैं आपको
कर दिखाता हूं हो ये टास्क में होगा सेटप
होगा चीज तो होगा ही चलिए यहां पर चीज दी
हुई है यूजिंग टरनेट वाज एफ टू ऑथेंटिकेट
एंड मैसे यूजर पासवर्ड थर्ड पार्टी च
नेटवर्क ठीक है वही दिया हुआ है कि टेलनेट
एफ है हमारे लिए मतलब ईमेल रिट्रीव करने
के लिए भी क्योंकि ये वाला प्रोटोकॉल भी
क्लियर टेक्स्ट है ठीक है और टेलेट आप
कहीं से भी जो भी क्लियर टेक्स्ट
प्रोटोकॉल है उससे कम्युनिकेशन में सवाल
कर सकते हैं चलिए
इन जनरल र ए वि कनेक्ट द पीओ सवर एमडीए
ठीक है ऑथेंटिक मैसे ल क थ न बहा दक
इंटरफेस कमांड विल बी य यहां पर वही दिया
हुआ है कि आपका जो एमज है कोई मे यें आप
कमांड इ करते नहीं बारबार ये स इंटरनल
वर्किंग है ठीक है वर्क कैसे कर रहा है आप
ी रिफ्रेश कर रहे आपको मिल जा रहे सारे तो
वो ऐसे ही वर्क कर रहा है ठीक है ना इटन
वर्किंग है वो आपको नहीं दिख रही है देखिए
एक और इंपोर्टेंट पॉइंट यहां पर बे न
डिफॉल्ट सेटिंग द ईमेल क्लाइंट डिलीट द
ईमेल मैसेज आफ्टर डाउनलोडेड मतलब क्या
आपका जो मेल क्लाउट है एक बार उसने एमडीएस
मैसेज ले लिया वो ईमेल वहां से डिलीट हो
जाएगा सर्वर से ठीक है द डिफॉल्ट बिहेवियर
कैन बी चेंज फ्रॉम द मेल क्लाइंट सेटिंग
इफ यू विश टू ाउनलोड द ईमेल्स अगेन फ्रॉम
द अनदर मिलक क्लाइंट ठीक है अगर आपको
अलग-अलग मिलक क्लाइंट से डाउनलोड करना है
तो आप सेटिंग को चेंज कर सकते हैं वरना बा
डिफॉल्ट कोई ईमेल जो एक बार डाउनलोड हो
गया इनबॉक्स में आ गया वो चला जाएगा वहां
से डिलीट हो जाएगा ठीक है चलिए देखिए ये
एक और चीज यहां पे इंपोर्टेंट एक्सेसिंग द
सेम मेल अकाउंट वया मल्टीपल क्लाइंट
यूजिंग पॉप थ यूजुअली नॉट वेरी कन्वेनिएंट
ठीक है एज वन वुड लूज ट्रैक ऑफ रेड एंड
रीड मैसेजेस का मतलब क्या मतलब ये आप
देखते हैं कि आप g
mail3 में पॉसिबल नहीं है ठीक है पथ में
वो चीज पॉसिबल नहीं है ठीक है ना वो चीज
इसमें पॉसिबल है आई में पॉसिबल है इसलिए
पप में लिमिटेशन आ जाती है हर चीज सही है
लेकिन जो डिफॉल्ट कन्फेशन है वो ये है कि
अगर एक बार आप डाउनलोड करते डिलीट हो
जाएगा आपके सर्वर से अगर आपने उस कन्फेशन
चेंज कर दिया तो ठीक है आप कि डाउनलोड कर
सकते हैं डिलीट नहीं होगा लेकिन स्टिल
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन नहीं हो पाएगा कि आप
मल्टीपल डिवाइस एक्सेस कर रहे हैं तो उस
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन के लिए हम आई का यूज करते
हैं ठीक है फिलहाल हम लोग पथ पे ही थोड़ा
ट्राई करते हैं जो य चीज दी हुई है फिर हम
आएंगे आई मैप पे
चलिए एड्रेस कॉपी रिपोर्ट इंडिकेट यूजिंग
यूजर नेम फ्रैंक एंड पासवर्ड ये व्ट इ दिस
पॉइंट यू गेट वि स्ट कमांड ठीक है अब हमें
क्या करना है यहां पर इसका पोर्ट देखना है
पोर्ट क्या होगा यहां पे 11 ठीक है चलिए
पप डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
110 क्लियर कर लेते हैं आई एड्रेस पेस्ट
करते हैं 110 पोर्ट प कनेक्ट करते हैं
कनेक्ट हमारा हो चुका है यहां पर ओके हेलो
देर ठीक कनेक्शन हो चुका है हमारा बन चुका
है हमें क्या करना है स्टेटस देखना है हम
करते हैं स्टेट कमांड ठीक है कुछ आ रहा
है ओके सॉरी हमने लॉगइन तो ऑलरेडी किया ही
नहीं है मेरे खल से यूजर लिखना पड़ेगा
पहले देख लेते हैं क्या है इसका ओके यूजर
के साथ ही हमें लिखना पड़ेगा यहां पर अपना
यूजर नेम भी र नेम क्या है फ्रैंक है ओके
पासवर्ड हमारा देख लेते हैं क्या है
पासवर्ड हमारा है ये इसको भी कॉपी कर लेते
हैं पेस्ट कर देते हैं इसको ठीक है हमारा
लॉगिन जो है सक्सेसफुल हो चुका है हम क्या
है यहां पर हम कैसे एकड कर रहे हैं यहां
पर हम यहां पर एक मेल क्लाइंट की तरह एकड
कर रहे हैं ठीक है हम क्या करने वाले हैं
अपने मैसेजेस को रिट्रीव करने वाले हैं
स्टेट से हम चेक करेंगे ओके 00 इसका मतलब
क्या जीरो साइज है इनबॉक्स की और जीरो ही
ईमेल जो है रिसीव हुआ है चलिए तो आंसर डाल
देते हैं य पर क्या होने वाला है प्लस ओके
जीरो
जीरो चलिए हाउ मेनी ईमेल्स मैसे अवेलेबल
लो प इतना कितने ईमेल मैसे अवेलेबल है
जीरो जीरो समझ में आया यहां समझ में आया
ठीक है बताया ऊपर लडी बात कर लेते आई की
चलिए आई क्या है इंटरनेट मैसेज एक्सेस
प्रोटोकॉल इन सब फुल फम आपको याद करने की
जरूरत नहीं है लेकिन बेसिक आप धीरे धीरे
आपको अपने आप फुल फॉम है वो याद हो जाएंगे
ठीक है ना यूज़ करते करते ये थोड़ा ज्यादा
एडवांस कह सकते हैं आप पथ का थोड़ा एडवांस
है क्योंकि मेक्स इट पॉसिबल टू कीप योर
ईमेल सिंक्रोनाइज्ड कहने का मतलब क्या
कहने का मतलब यही चीज दोबारा मैं इसमें
समझाता हूं अच्छे से आपको समझ में आएगा हो
सकता
है चलिए जैसे यहां पर आपका क्या है आपका
यहां पर
ये मेल बॉक्स है ठीक है मेल बॉक्स अब यहां
पर आपका क्या है अलग-अलग क्लाइंट है ये
आपका क्लाइंट वन है ये आपका क्लाइंट टू है
ये आपका क्लाइंट थ्री है ठीक है इसमें
सारे मेल है अब हर आदमी को यहां से क्या
करना है मेल को रिट्रीव करना है हर आदमी
को यहा से मेल को रिट्रीव करना है अब ये
पहला य पर ये क्या है य जो मेल बॉक्स है
आपका वो आपका मेल डिलीवरी एजेंट है ठीक है
सबको य मेल देने वाला है और य हम कौन से
प्रोटोकॉल यूज करेंगे य पर यूज करने वाले
हैं पोस्ट ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन थ पोस्ट
ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन थ यहां पर भी वही
यूज होगा ठीक है और यहां पर भी य
होगा चलिए न रिट्रीव कर मान लीजिए इसने
पहले वाले ने ठीक है ये जो ए बंदा है इसने
पहले वाले बंदे ने कोई मेल सीन कर लिया
ठीक है पहले बंदे ने मेल को सीन कर लिया
दूसरे वाले मतलब दूसरा वा बंदा मतलब बंदा
सेम ही है ठीक है लेकिन अलग-अलग डिवाइस से
लॉगइन कर रखा है इसने इसको पता नहीं चलेगा
कि वो मेल सीन है या नहीं है ठीक है ज इस
डिवाइस से देखोगे तो वहां प फिरन नहीं
रहेगा एक तरीके से ठीक है बाय डिफॉल्ट जब
ये डाउनलोड कर लेगा पहला वाला जब डाउनलोड
कर लेगा मैसेज को तो डिलीट हो जाएगा यहां
से ठीक डिलीट हो जाएगा यहां से लेकिन
चूंकि डिलीट जब हमने जो कन्फेशन डिफॉल्ट
वाली उसको चेंज कर दिया है इसलिए वो डिलीट
नहीं होगा हो लेकिन ये चीज है कि मतलब सीन
अनसीन वाला ये तो कन्फेशन से फर्क नहीं
पड़ता ये पथ काम ही ऐसे करता है कि यहां
सेसे सीन कर लिया गया ये बात इसको नहीं
पता लेगी और ना इसको पता लेगी ठीक है ना
वो क्या समझेंगे कि मैसेज नहीं सीन है ठीक
है तो आपको पता नहीं चलेगा कौन से वा
डिवाइस से कम मैसेज सीन किया गया कौन का
मैसेज नहीं सील किया गया इस प्रॉब्लम को
सॉल्व कौन कर रहा है इस प्रॉब्लम को सॉल्व
कर रहा है आई मैप आपका ठीक है इस प्रॉब्लम
को सॉल्व कर रहा है कौन आपका आई
मैप येम सॉल्व करर हैई अगर आपके और कुछ
डिवाइस है ठीक है ना और कुछ डिवाइस है जो
कि आई के थ्रू इंटरेक्ट कर रहे है
आपके पर आपका य हो रहा है क्या आई मैप ठीक
है ऐसे में क्या होगा कि यह जो
सिंक्रनाइजेशन है वो इी हो जाएगा मतलब
इसने देख लिया इसको पता चलेगा इसको पता
चलेगा ठीक है किसीने देखा किने कुछ किया
तो व सारे लोगों को पता लेगा बाकी डिवाइस
को ठीक है ना ये आपका क्या कर देगा आई में
हेल्प कर देगा आपका
चलिए दिया हुआ है देखिए चेंस विल बी सेव न
द आई सर्वर ठीक क्या है जैसे की हमने अपने
एमडीए को पॉप यूज करने वाले केस में पप
सर्वर कहा था उस तरीके से जब हम अपना क्या
यज कर रहे करको स कह सकते ठीक है एमडी को
इस एमडी को हम क्या करने वाले व भी कने
वाले आ देखते क्याय पर य पर ने किया गया
बस सिटेक्स कमांड है इसके जैसे कि यहां पर
क्या है पहला कमांड आपका यहां पर लॉगिन है
लॉगिन के बाद यूजर नेम पासवर्ड देना है
आपको ठीक है इन्होंने भी वही किया है
लॉगिन यहां पर ठीक है देखिए लॉगिन फ्रैंक
और ये अब ये c1 आगे क्या लगा हुआ है ठीक
है यहां पर एक नोट करने वाली चीज है यहां
पर लिखा भी होगा मेरे ख्याल से कहीं पे
देखिए आई मैप रिक्वायर्स ईच कमांड टू बी
प्रोसीडेड बाय रैंडम स्ट्रिंग हर कमांड से
पहले आपको एक रैंडम स्ट्रिंग लगाना है टू
बी एबल ट ट्रैक द रिप्लाई रिप्लाई को
ट्रैक कर सक कहने का मतलब क्या जैसे यहां
पर आपका ये है c1 ठीक है लॉगिन फ्रैंक
कितना ठीक है यहां पर क्या आया ये पूरा
आपका आया ठीक है फिर यहां पर क्या सव ओके
लगन समझ में य तक आपका रिप्लाई था ठीक है
ना चलिए य हमने इस तरीके से स2 ऐड किया है
य परव हमारा इसमें था और सी2 हमारा ये
दूसरा कमांड है सी2 वाला ठीक है इसके
आउटपुट में य पर सी2 दिया हुआ है समझ स
इसी का आउटपुट है ठीक है चलिए य पर हमने
पह कौन स प डाली लगन यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड
ठीक है इस से कॉपी कर लेता हूं ल से टास्क
भी है हमारा सव ही कर लेते हैं हम भी कुछ
भी लिख सकते की जगह सबसे पहले तो यही नहीं
किया हमने कर लेते हैं यार च आई का
डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट क्या है आ का डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
है 143 चलिए कनेट सॉरी 143 पक करते हैं
इसको पेस्ट करते हैं यहां पर एंटर बते हैं
लॉगइन हमारा हो चुका है देखिए c1 ओके
लॉगइन ओके आ गया ठीक है आगे हम क्या करने
वाले हैं इसके यहां पर इसका मान करने वाले
हैं इसका मतलब क्या है लिस्ट ये लिस्ट
यहां पर ये स्टार डला हुआ है ठीक है इसका
मतलब क्या देखिए देन व लिस्टेड आवर मेल
फोल्डर्स यूजिंग इससे आपने मेल फोल्डर्स ख
सकते हैं दिखाता हूं आपको पेस्ट करते हैं
इसको
एंटर करते है क्या गया आपका इनबॉक्स
ड्राफ्ट अब आपको समझ मेडर का मतलब क्या है
आपके होता है नाम ड्राफ्ट होता है सट होता
है आपका आउटगोइंग होता है मतलब आ सॉरी
मुझे याद नहीं रहा उसका क्या नाम रता है
एकली जहा आपका जो मेल सेंट हो र होते
करेंटली वो होते है ठीक है ना देख लेते
हैं इसको आ आउट बॉक्स होता हैद हा य य पर
होंगे कोई नहीं य दिख रहा
है नहीं जो मेल सेंड हो रहे होते हैं वो
भी होते हैं इस तरीके अलग फोल्डर होते हैं
उ साड करते हैं ठीक है इनबॉक्स में ट्रैश
में स्पैम में ट्रैश में डिलीटेड मेल्स
होते हैं वो सब चीजें यहां पर ठीक है चलिए
यहां पर क्या हुआ इसने यहां पर ये आपका
ओके आउटपुट आ गया ठीक है हमने क्या किया
एग्जामिन इनबॉक्स यानी इनबॉक्स में जाओ
ठीक है c3 एग्जामिन इनबॉक्स इसको भी कर
लेते हैं अब ये c3 लिखिए c1 लिखिए c2
लिखिए चा कुछ और लिखिए आपकी मर्जी है वो
रैंडम स्ट्रिंग है चलिए रा क्या आ गया
हमारा एग्जामिन लगा ठीक है यहां से हमने
डाला c3 एग्जामिन इन बॉक्स ये आ गया स्ल
ड्राफ्ट आंसर फल के बारे में ठीक है जीरो
जीरो ें ठीक है स बस व मिल गई आगे देखते
क्या य पर य पर क्या लग आउट ठीक है लग आउट
करने का य क्या दिया ों नी टू मेमोरा य पर
दी हुई है पर हमारा कोई मैसेज नहीं तो
क्या दिखा इसम य पर दी हुई है कोसे हो तो
य पर मिल जाएगा एमन बक्स दिया हुआ है
मैसेज नहीं ल कर सकते लट से ठीक है ल
करना
ल्ट अभी देखा
हमने
चलिए अब हम आ गए समरी प समरी में क्या है
सारे प्रोटोकॉल उनका वर्जन ठीक है क्या
समझ में आया आपको यहां पर इसका सारे
क्लियर टेक्स्ट है ठीक जितने भी इस रूम
में हमने पढ़े सारे के सारे क्लियर
टेक्स्ट है फिर भी हम यूज करती है कुछ
अल्टरनेटिव भी है लेकिन फिर भी हम क जगह
यज करना पड़ता हैट काफी ह तक नहीं ता
लेकिन एस है उसकी जगह ठीक है ना तो इस कट
करते पहले इसके दूसरा करने वाले जो कि आज
के लेक्चर में हम नहीं करेंगे ठीक है अगले
लेक्चर में करेंगे इस रूम को य से ये लडी
लंबा हो चुका है मैं आपको लेकिन एक पहले
बताता हं सते कौन सा रूम की बात कर रहा
हूं आपको य
पर दिखाता
हूं से चैलेंज
नाम देख लेते हैं इसको कौन सा रूम था
हमारा नेट सर्विसेस य ू खोल दिया पहले ही
ये
वाला हम पहले उसके बात करेंगे ये रूम
ऑलरेडी सॉल्वड है शायद पहले से मेरा लिए
कोई नहीं इसको हम लोग रिट कर लेंगे ठीक है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है य मैंने कब किया मुझे
भी याद नहीं है पहले क होगा कभी हम यहां
पर क्या करेंगे हम पहले एसएमबी को समझेंगे
ठीक है एसएमबी क्या होता है कैसे होता है
मैंने थोड़ा बताया फिर भी हम डिटेल में
आपस देखेंगे इस वाले रू में हम क्या करने
वाले हैं एमबी को डिटेल में समझेंगे एमेशन
समझेंगे उसका समझेंगे फिर हम टेनेट प
आएंगे जो मैंने आपको आज रिवाइज करवाया नेट
को वापस सेय बेसिक अंडरस्टैंड है बस और
कुछ नहीं है एट करना सीखेंगे और एक्सट
करेंगे करेंगे ठीक है सेम तरीके से एफटीपी
हमने जाना है एफटीपी को हम अंडरस्टैंड
करेंगे एनरेटक करना सीखेंगे ठीक है मिसक
फिगरेशन बाकी चीजें और एक्सपोर्टेशन
सीखेंगे और फिर हम लोग अगले रूम में आएंगे
ठीक है नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी चैलेंज वाला ही
अगले रूम में आएंगे उसको भी सॉल्व करेंगे
ये पूरा करने के बाद हम वापस से जिस
मॉड्यूल को हम सॉल्व कर रहे थे वापस चले
आएंगे ठीक है क्योंकि हमारा कोई मॉड्यूल
सॉल्व करना तो नहीं है हमारा एम है कि एक
स्ट्रक्चर पा से होना चाहिए जो कि आपको
ट्रा में बहुत अच्छी तरीके से प्रोवाइड
करता है इसीलिए हम इस प्लेटफॉर्म का यूज
कर रहे हैं लेकिन जहां भी आपको एक्स्ट्रा
चीज मुझे लग रही है ड जरूरत है वहां मैं
ऐड कर दे रहा हूं और जो भी रूम मॉड्यूल के
बाहर के भी है लेकिन लगता है कि वहां
जरूरत है वो मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ठीक है
क्योंकि एबी काफी इंपोर्टेंट है उससे रि
मैं कुछ आपको भी दिखाऊंगा और लास्ट में ये
सब करने के बाद हम अपने चैलेंस को सॉल्व
करेंगे सीटीएस को सॉल्व करेंगे और होप
फुली अभी तो नहीं पर बाद में हमारी तरफ से
भी कुछ चैनल आ सकता है आपके लिए मतलब ये
पूरे कांसेप्ट को अप्लाई करने के आपके लिए
भी कुछ चैले आ सकता है जो हमने डिजाइन
किया होगा ठीक है देखते हैं म कब तक होती
है लेकिन फिलहाल आपके लिए ये चीज तो
रहेंगी और ट्राक मी के या फिर किसी और
प्लेटफॉर्म के में आपको लैब्स चैलेंज वाले
मतलब सब कुछ सीखने के बाद फाइनल हम
प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे ठीक है हो सकता है व
लाइव भी हो तो अटेंड आप पूरा करते रहिए
नेटवक सिक्य आराम से भी चल रहा है तो कोई
दिक्कत भी नहीं होगी मेरे ख्याल से कवर
करने में काफी स्लो फिल्म चल रहा है ठीक
है मतलब अभी तो 9 10 लेक्चर हुए हैं बस
ठीक है तो इसको कंप्लीट कीजिएगा पोस्ट को
अपने लिंग प जरूर शेयर कीजिएगा पक्का
कीजिएगा इससे आपका नेटवर्क तो स्ट्रांग
होता ही है आपकी जो एबिलिटी बढ़ती है वो
बढ़ती ही है ठीक है साथ में आपको आगे
हमारी तरफ से भी और मौके मिलेंगे जब आप
हमारे नजर में रहते हैं तो हम कोई भी
कंपशन कुछ भी करेंगे तो उसमें आपको बफिट
मिलेगा कैसे मिलेगा बताऊंगा मैं आपको बाद
में तो चैनल सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिएगा और ऐप
को डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा उसमें आपको सारे
लेटेस्ट कोर्सेस चीजें जो भी है आपको ये
कैप्सूल कोर्स भी मिल जाएंगे यहां पे कुछ
भी नया आपको मिलेगा तो वहां मिल जाएगा प
पे ठीक है तो वो भी इंस्टॉल कर दीजिएगा
चलिए तो आज के लेक्चर में इतना ही पे एंड
करते हैं हम लोग मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लेक्चर
में में थैंक्स फॉर वाचिंग